questo parcheggio è protagonista di una
storia che mi ha raccontato una mia
amica è un parcheggio abbastanza anonimo
e sta san cesario sul panaro in
provincia di modena un paesino di 6 mila
abitanti è il parcheggio del centro
sportivo arci quindi è stata a volte una
balera a volte è stato la sala riunioni
a volte ci hanno fatto anche delle feste
la storia inizia così febbraio di alcuni
anni fa al circolo arci di san cesario
c'è la festa di carnevale
una roba trash musica dance e tutti i
giovani senza alternative e convergono
qui la mia amica non ha voglia di
andarci ma la sua migliore amica ha una
tresca ea dai biglietti quindi deve
accompagnarla si diverte si devono anche
travestire sono batman e robin arrivano
del parcheggio che freddo alla
calzamaglia le fanno male le scarpe
anche la pipì quindi proprio arriva col
mood peggiore possibile nel parcheggio
nel parcheggio però c'è qualcosa di
strano c'è una panda rossa appoggiati
alla panda rossa ci sono due ragazzi che
stanno distribuendo gin tonic a le
persone che entrano perché è la festa è
piena e quindi non si riesce più entrare
a meno che non si conosca qualcuno le
due ragazze si fermano la mia amica
guarda uno di questi ragazzi negli occhi
e bun colpo di fulmine amore a prima
vista letteralmente il parcheggio cambia
colore alla campagna iniziata intimare
parlano e lei ha la conferma questo è
l'uomo della mia vita
quante dove avete conosciuto voi
la donna della vostra vita all'uomo
della vostra vita imposti belli alla
reggia di caserta o eravate in quel
sottoscala nelle scale avete bocciato
per la prima volta qualcuno nella panda
sono le nostre memorie che spesso
decidono la natura dei luoghi che in cui
viviamo ci sono memorie belle quindi ci
sono posti che ti emozionano ci sono
memorie brutte ci sono anche posti che a
volte ci fanno stare male però c'è
comunque una connessione
il problema viene quando noi non abbiamo
nessuna memoria dei posti quando ci sono
dei posti che semplicemente
attraversiamo che sono lo sfondo della
nostra vita che sono un fondale grigio e
senza memoria
ecco la nostra battaglia è nello
sconfiggere questi posti è nel fare sì
che attraverso una delle tecniche più
antiche dell'uomo e più potenti si
abbiano delle memorie anche di questi
spazi
quello che noi facciamo è utilizzare il
gioco perché quando giochiamo
entriamo in una dimensione che ci porta
molto più in profondità molto simile a
quella che si prova quando si è
innamorati ci riusciamo a creare dei
ricordi che rimangono con noi per
veramente tanto tempo we sing ha nel suo
libro homo ludens lo definisce il
cerchio magico
in pratica quando giochiamo noi facciamo
un patto sociale con le altre persone
che stanno giocando e diciamo bene noi
decidiamo di sottostare a delle regole
che non sempre sono sensate decidiamo
che il gioco ha dei limiti spaziali e
decidiamo che gioca una durata ha dei
limiti temporali
se volete capirlo meglio pensate a un
campo da calcio cioè il fuori quando la
palla esce a si deve rimettere in campo
c'è una durata ci sono il primo e il
secondo tempo e ci sono delle regole
perché un pallone e bisogna calciarlo
invece che usare le mani o altre cose di
questo tipo quando rientriamo nel
cerchio magico è come se la nostra testa
cambiasse un po e riusciamo ad andare
molto più in profondità con le nostre
memorie il tema però è le linee che
delimitano la zona di gioco se lo devono
essere per forza disegnate noi crediamo
di no ci sono dei nei giochi urbani
quello che succede che le linee sono
nella testa di chi sta giocando non è
cesar che ci siano sempre dei confini è
abbastanza che tra noi si faccia un pad
si decida che si vuole giocare
noi facciamo giochi da tanti anni
scritta dal 2009 abbiamo iniziato a
matera per l'altro e tre le camene tanti
i legali e illegali oggi ve ne racconto
uno che è particolarmente legata a
questa città nel 2013
il comitato matera 2019 stava lavorando
come dei forsennati alla candidatura e
dovevano si erano presentati però come
una candidatura di tutta la regione
quindi avevano bisogno di parlare a
tutte le fasce della popolazione e
c'erano anche delle parti della
popolazione che non erano proprio sul
tema sul pezzo
quindi ha fatto un bando per cercare una
soluzione a questo problema noi abbiamo
partecipato e abbiamo vinto il bando e
abbiamo fatto il nostro progetto che la
gni basilicata boardgames praticamente
dovevamo riuscire a convincere ea far
sapere a queste persone che c'era la
candidatura e sono stati sostanzialmente
un festival di due mesi in cui siamo
andati in diverse città della basilicata
a giocare però verso abbiamo attraverso
la verso le faccio vedere il primo
elemento però di questo gioco era e
abbia fatto una colpe a chiamare in
basilicata a 120 persone creativi che
venivano da tutta europa erano sia
appunto europei dato che la candidatura
era europea volevamo portare un po di
energia e infatti per loro ovviamente la
basilicata non sapevano dove fosse
semplicemente gli stavamo regalando una
settimana di giochi nel sud italia
quindi 0 pregiudizi 0 per i concetti
super carichi e quello che abbiamo
appunto portato è stata energia tanta
energia da fuori questo il primo
elemento
il secondo elemento era questo abbiamo
giocato in diverse città e quando
dicevamo che una delle città e la
potenza tutti ci dicevano
vabbè potenza nessuno vorrà iscriversi
non verrà nessuno ha piena di scale un
macello
noi che anche noi siamo un po come nei
giocatori c'è una grande per l'edizione
lavandai stati qua come detto chissà
non lo so però comunque avanti ha deciso
che secondo ingrediente del gioco
sarebbe stato cambiare la geografia dei
posti e questa è una cosa che ci insegna
anche lynch nel suo libro l'immagine
della città per cui anche come
raccontiamo i posti cambia molto come
come decidiamo di viverli
quindi noi abbiamo fatto una bella mappa
colorata di potenza in cui quartiere
hanno tutti colorati e
ma anche nome e avevamo saint rock che
era san rocco
avevamo lima invece che santa maria ma
il mio preferito personalmente era
poggio tre galli che è diventato thrixxx
e o cioè gli viene già voglia di andare
lì e ne fanno un sacco di cose quindi il
secondo ingrediente dell'alterazione
della geografia cioè entro in uno spazio
magico perché è perché lo chiami anche
in modo diverso questa cosa
aiutaci a dei famosi limiti che tutti
noi abbiamo nella nostra testa
il terzo ingrediente è che c'è tra il
pubblico tra l'altro abbiamo messa no
non è comunque è il terzo ingrediente è
quello di farsi contaminare non possiamo
atterrare con i nostri giochi in un post
dire ok si fa così quindi quello che
abbiamo fatto è stato chiedere alle
persone di potenza di ospitare in casa
loro i giocatori
questo cosa ha creato un sacco di
energia nel senso che le persone
dormivano lì imparavano il dialetto
imparavano la ricetta è anche le persone
cioè i potentini hanno visto potenza con
gli occhi di qualcuno che non aveva
pregiudizi quindi con gli occhi dello
straniero e sono e ogni giorno sentivano
raccontare delle cose assolutamente
assurda con un telegiornale di follie
che veniva recapitato ogni sera nelle
case di chi ha deciso di farsi
contaminare quindi era mix è il terzo
ingrediente anche noi abbiamo dovuto
remix archi nel senso noi siamo siamo
basati a milano e quando siamo arrivati
qua abbiamo avuto dei partner che ci
hanno aiutato appunto a organizzare il
tutto
un part nella punta della casa network
di materia che è stato il partner
diciamo del del progetto ma soprattutto
qua a potenza in particolare abbiamo
avuto la luna al guinzaglio
se volete fargli un applauso stati
bravissimi e che ci hanno ci hanno
aiutato a portare le idee che avevamo
sul territorio e quindi anche noi ci
siamo fatti contaminare uguale memorie
assurde e indelebili e molto commoventi
nella testa si sia di chi ha giocato che
si sia di chi ha visto il gioco quindi
abbiamo giocato sotto dei monumenti
incredibili alla mattina però c'eravamo
andati alle 5 di mattina a fare
meditazione in cima quindi abbiamo fatto
meditazione nel ponte musmeci e stato
molto bello abbiamo fatto partire dei
giochi
delle cappe e ladri in cui abbiamo
coinvolto centinaia di persone da dei
posti molto qui vicino
abbiamo messo la morte messicana
accompagnata da un avvocato sulla salita
di san gerardo abbiamo messo delle
scimmie in giro c'era un pazzo da sedare
al parco baden powell e tutte le sere ci
trovavamo in piazza e la prefettura a
ballare a giocare e ogni sera sarà
sempre più persone che decidevano che
quello era uno spazio che volevano
vivere con noi le memorie sono una cosa
molto potente che ci fa quindi re
immaginare lo spazio in cui viviamo e
secondo me i giochi urbani sono una
specie di colpo di fulmine cioè sono
qualcosa che ti shakera che ti è un
uragano che arrivati dice ma io non sto
vivendo in questo posto a 15 anni molto
diverso da come lo immaginavo perché dal
dal gioco urbano possono partire una
serie di di grandi storie di altre cose
e quindi per me è appunto è stato un po
come un colpo di fulmine venire qui a
fare i vivi games perché da lì è nata
tutta una storia molto diversa e se
torniamo e siamo anche riusciti tra
l'altro nel nostro intento di
coinvolgere certe fasce della
popolazione
questa cosa sta succedendo in tutto il
mondo nel senso ci sono giochi urbani in
giro per l'europa questo ad esempio un
festival che è stato appena adesso ai a
cracovia in polonia in polonia ci sono
avventure che potrebbero adattarsi bene
a degli incompiuti siciliani
qua siamo in russia dove fanno delle
avventure assurde imposti poche post
apocalittici
oppure ci sono ad esempio delle corse
che ho sognato anche stanotte tra
l'altro perché ne abbiamo parlato ieri
qui in inghilterra ad esempio fanno
delle cose in cui tu di notte dei
ricorsi e in seguito dagli zombie per me
quindi si giochi urbani sono qualcosa
che secondo me ha molte potenzialità si
adatta bene a qualsiasi territorio e
chiara delle memorie che hanno veramente
tanto tanto impatto nella vita delle
persone
torniamo un attimo però al parcheggio un
parcheggio anonimo di cui voi non
sapevate l'esistenza che però adesso
grazie alla panda forse a da una
connessione per voi perché il quarto
ingrediente segreto è quello di
raccontare storie possibili delle cose
che succedono dei nostri spazi se noi le
cose che succedono ce li teniamo per noi
le belle memorie
ecco che questa cosa non si rifonda
invece se riusciamo a parlarne
allora anche per voi questo parcheggio
anonimo è comunque qualcosa di speciale
perché perché lì è iniziata una storia
d'amore
il protagonista della nostra storia
ottavi ha trovato il suo futuro marito
da quel momento sono nate una serie di
storie incredibili che hanno unito
queste due persone in particolare anche
per me quel parcheggio è molto
importante perché è proprio in quel
parcheggio che ho conosciuto mia moglie
la persona di cui mi sono innamorato